Your skin is an incredible organ, it holds
you together, keeps invading pathogens from
killing you, and also doesn't do this.
Howdy skin jobs.
Natalia here.
Happy Halloween and thanks for tuning into
DNews!
Skin is the largest organ of your body.
I've already mentioned a couple of the benefits
of having skin -- but here are a few more:
it grows hair to protect itself, it sweats
to cool the body down, has goosebumps to warm
us up, it’s self healing, and senses the
world around us…
Seriously, we're wrapped up in one of the
most fantastic materials!
But, there's one thing that vertebrate skin
doesn't do easily, and that's tear.
A good example here is, leather: cow skin.
Motorcyclists wear it because if they crash
it doesn't rip or break… it just skids,
protecting their actual skin with other skin!
Weird.
In fact, leather should skid longer than either
denim or bulletproof kevlar.
Textile companies test the strengths of leather
in what they call "breaking strength" tests.
Basically, they attach two clamps and stretch
it until it tears.
One company published that the breaking strength
of a 3-inch sample should never be less than
150 pounds.
Remember, leather is just SKIN.
So how can skin hold up against so much force?
Well, because of its construction.
Firstly, a bit about skin: not all skin is
the same thickness.
The skin of the foot or the back is 4 millimeters
thick, while the skin of the genitals and
eyelids is way thinner.
In that cross section, there are three layers:
the epidermis, dermis, and hypodermis -- but
the dermis is the thickest.
When you stretch your skin (like this) Hey,
I'm kinda stretchy!
You'll feel it pull back on you because of
the 'type 1' collagen: a super-common coiled
triple-helix protein.
The stuff that lets it bounce back is called
elastin: a network of fibers that help with,
what else, skin elasticity (helping it hold
its shape when it's stretched or bent).
But even though we knew all this, a new study
in Nature Communications found out why it
can stretch, but doesn't tear!
They found that the skin's actual fibers will
rotate, straighten, stretch and slide, to
keep the skin from ripping!
Skin evolved to try and spread the stress
from a hole, notch, or tear!
That's so crazy, right?
Normally collagen is disordered and chaotic,
spread randomly throughout in our skin, but
when skin is pulled, stretched or hooked into
some kind of horror gore torture device…
These spiraled collagen fibrils reorient themselves,
and align along the pull, resisting a tear,
and keeping the inside of your body protected!
Researchers used rabbit skin, and a sophisticated
synchrotron x-ray machine to watch the collagen
in action, and postulated that this is also
how our own stretchy stuff gets its pluck.
According to their studies, understanding
this behavior could help improve synthetic
and flexible fabrics, which currently use
stuff like wheat gluten.
Gluten is like glue that holds bread together,
and it doesn't tear easily either!
Skin is more tear-resistant than gluten!?
That's a weird fact.
As long as we're facting it up: beauty products
often say they have elastin in them, just
like your skin, but it comes from cows or
birds and if you rub elastin on your face,
it still doesn't go under the epidermis into
the dermis.
Sorry.
Womp womp.
Anyway, thanks to skin being so darn tear
resistant, some humans can even put hooks
through it and hang their whole bodies from
the ceiling.
It's been done for 1000s of years for ceremonial
and religious purposes, and it's still done
today!
Skin is amazing.
Happy Halloween!!
MUAHAHAHAHA!!
Have you ever thought about how your skin
needs sunlight to make vitamin D?
What's going on inside your skin?
Is it really MAKING vitamins?
Find out here:
What's your favorite organ?
I like the skin, for sure -- but I've always
wondered about the spleen.
Such a weird word.
Let us know down in the comments below and
don’t forget to subscribe to DNews for a
new episode every day of the week.